for her very first tv interview since
testing positive for covert 19 white
house press secretary kelly mcinanny
uh well i know it's probably going to be
scary for you it's scary for everybody
um you have an eight-month-old daughter
first how are you feeling do you know
maybe how when where i guess nobody
really knows when they contract this
yeah i'm feeling great i'm having no
symptoms you know i'm very blessed to um
have a mild case or really just an
asymptomatic case you know my heart goes
out to all of those who have been
affected by this
um and all those who have lost their
lives but i'm pleased to see that
our commander-in-chief is doing well
watching him on that balcony
uh just showing that we will overcome
america will overcome just as he is
overcoming this illness i think was a
really nice moment for our country to
see
there's also you know we we can't forget
the medical geniuses the researchers the
scientists
uh regeneron remdi severe
i don't want to get back into the
hydroxychloroquine but many doctors
swear by it
put that aside for a minute but all the
other therapeutics that we've developed
and again
you know between fisa moderner and
astrazeneca and other companies you know
final stage trial for a vaccine 10
months after
the first identified case of corona in
america that is historic
and miraculous in its own right you make
a very good point sean
the fact that this president president
trump was able to tear down bureaucratic
red tape get us dexamethasone
remdessevere monoclonal antibodies
these landmark treatments and
therapeutics this was a novel virus that
came in from china
no one had seen it there were no tests
there were no therapeutics in short
order president trump developed them
and this vaccine is on pace to be the
faxes vaccine
for a novel pathogen in human history
and we can thank president trump for all
of that
all right kaylee everyone's praying for
you and your family for a quick and
speedy recovery
thank you for being with us joining